I hear all the time people saying well
at the heart and at the basics of the
soul that all these religions are
basically the same
when people say that to me it tells me
immediately they don't know anything
about the world religions
and they know even less about the
Christian faith
welcome to LED live it's a show where we
use the Light of Christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today and today we have Stephanie
Griffin with us welcome how are you I'm
great happy to be here and we also have
Eric Wilson we haven't seen you in a
while how you doing
it's good to see you
so we're going to be discussing the
emerging church today and that could
mean different things to a lot of
different people so I'm going to hand it
over to you to first like set the stage
as to what that even means and then take
us through the topic okay
well the emerging Church what is it you
know it's it's very Broad and most
people don't understand what it means
but we're gonna find out today if we're
going to show a video that kind of
introduces the topic and then we're
going to go and talk about it a little
bit okay
it's not uncommon for people to seek God
during times of hardship and in some
ways the pandemic has been no different
but even before covet a growing number
of Americans were moving away from
organized religions and the pandemic
didn't do anything to stop that Trend a
survey this month from the Pew Research
Center found 29 said they had no
religious affiliation that's up six
points from 2016 with the millennial
generation leading that shift so with
the pandemic dragging on into its third
year cnbc's SEMA Modi tells us Faith
leaders are trying new ways to reach out
and touch someone
more Progressive religions are gaining
popularity Middle Collegiate Church grew
by 500 members during the pandemic even
though its actual building was destroyed
by a fire last year we've put
social justice and democracy in the
middle of faith in a way that really
speaks to Young Folks some critics would
say you're changing their relationship
with God that what you're doing is is
different than the traditional approach
what's your response I'm so glad I'm
changing their relationship to God if
that's what we're doing that's exciting
to me I'm trying to get God out of the
box remember Perrin Allen grew up in a
Conservative Christian household but as
a gay man struggled to feel accepted you
had to do things the way the Bible says
literally but I feel like the Bible and
Jesus Christ believed in Love no matter
what and I feel like I found that
admittal it's not just love since the
pandemic spiritual leader Deepak Chopra
says people are yearning for connection
and Community the pandemic showed us
that people don't like isolation
surprise Foundation is hosting Retreats
where the spiritually minded come to
heal meditate and connect we are
creating both online and offline
communities globally Rabbi Stanton views
these changes as a spiritual awakening
not just for people but the faith
community as a whole institutions are
going to shift dramatically and we are
all going to be the better off for it
whether at churches like this one on
social media or at spiritual Retreats
religious leaders we spoke to say the
pandemic has fostered a stronger
connection to spirituality in younger
generations and see it as an opportunity
to engage with them so did you hear
it's built on change right it's the
church reimagined so what does that look
like how do we reimagine church we heard
some key words in there the gentleman
said that
the Bible was literal but he feels
that's right right he feels yeah and
then you heard change and then you heard
meditate
you heard spiritual retreats
so you kind of get an inkling of where
we're headed with this it can go out of
the box yes out of the box right yeah
what was interesting to me was
when that man said you know the Bible
you know is supposed to be taken
literally but I feel
all of a sudden
truth becomes how he feels not what
God's word says
and that's that's very dangerous my
experience over over the word of God
you know
um
the people in this video they seem to be
fighting against uh
the feeling of being isolated or removed
they're wondering this community
but that's something that was already
instituted in God's word it's something
that God understands that we need as
human beings and he says the Bible says
in second Timothy chapter 3 verse 16
that all scripture is given by
inspiration of God and it's profitable
not just for Doctrine you know not just
to be taken literally but for reproof
for correction for instruction in
righteousness that the man of God may be
perfect thoroughly furnished until all
good works and included in all of that
it's kind of hitting all the areas of
life including community and I think
it's when we remove ourselves from the
ideal that we start feeling these
going to the I feel you know I feel the
emptiness I feel this I feel that and
then trying to compensate for what God
has already provided in his word and
then there's this caution in Revelation
revelation 22 that we should not be
changing the words of the Bible the
words of God's word to us and so
it's it's great that when you know the
truth you're able to pick up on those
buzzwords and be like well no
something's wrong here even if you don't
exactly know what you have that
intuition that's Holy Spirit given to be
like yeah let's look deeper into this
because something isn't quite right yeah
what I think is interesting is the need
to change the system without changing
ourselves right it's just like taking
that aspect out of it and when we come
to Christ there is a transformation
process but it seems like people don't
want to transform they want God to do
the transforming to how they feel like
he should be and that's a problem it
would also be interesting to hear what
God is to the people in this video a lot
of times our image of God comes from our
person-to-person experiences and so the
either the traumas we experience or the
just difficult times when it comes to an
individual now all of a sudden god's
picture is now that that person's face
or the experience or what have you and
so in trying to change the system maybe
it's not necessarily the system that's
broken it's our interpersonal
relationships which is the one of those
is to grow our character is to survives
above that sea above that into the
Perfection of who God is and how he can
transform messages right which is the
point that you made into His Image
rather than making him into our image I
was surprised that it was just 29 I
thought it was high I thought it was
going to be higher too and yes there is
a push to secular secularism is that the
word in this country uh and they
pinpointed the group millennials
I think the number is even higher with
the Gen Z
have you identified why that's the case
yeah that's the post-modern mindset
right so post-modern we don't have
dividing lines we're not nationalists we
are we citizens of the world
we're not a Baptist or a Methodist we
are a non-denominational we bring
everything together we just take down
those walls and of course it's
experience based so my truth is no
longer science no longer facts but my
experience so that's consistent with
with what's happened since World War II
all right so our next video is going to
be a little more descriptive about
emergent worship what it looks like
[Music]
my name is Brian Mclaren and the book is
called why did Jesus Moses the Buddha
and Muhammad cross the road Christian
identity and a multi-faith world
you know the emerging church is an
interesting term for some it is the way
that a church expresses itself it's the
methods that they use it's the way that
the place looks it's full of couches
rather than sort of thing and for others
of us it's much more deep than that it's
about how we view the world 46 minutes
past the hour right now good morning to
you so some 2020 Democratic candidates
seem to like to keep religion separate
from politics but evangelicals represent
a pretty large segment of the electorate
our next guest tells the New Yorker that
many moderate evangelicals will be happy
to vote for Democrats but they feel the
party overlooks them during campaigns
joining us is Pastor Doug Patchett of
Solomon's porch Church in Minneapolis he
created an organization to make the
religious left more visible and help
Democrats learn how to court Evangelical
voters pageant also worked on behalf of
the Obama campaign in 2008. good morning
to you sir thank you for joining us
somewhere along the way the Jesus
movement Got Hijacked
Rob Bell has been raising a lot of
eyebrows lately for his evolving views
about Christianity and the Bible some
evangelicals are calling it twisted
scripture also inspiring charges of
heresy it is my honor to welcome to the
show live in studio Rob Bell everybody
rob now
the religions have failed so we are
going through a revolution because these
great Traditions have to be expanded I
believe the the man is a false teacher I
believe he's a heretic he is a paradigm
shifter more than he realizes men like
Rob Bell they claim to be working of God
women's rights LGBT minorities love of
our Muslim neighbors if those aren't all
Basics you're done Rob Bell should
liar and he's a heretic
well Church Pastor Rob Bell has been
raising a lot of eyebrows lately for his
evolving views about Christianity and
the Bible Bell and his wife Kirsten
recently appeared with Oprah Winfrey on
her Super Soul Sunday program where he
suggested the Bible is irrelevant to
today's culture take a look at this
short clip
one of the oldest aches and the bones of
humanity is loneliness
and it's one of the things that goes way
way back loneliness is not good for the
world
and so whoever you are gay or straight
it is totally normal natural and healthy
you don't want somebody to go through
life with
hi I'm Rick Warren and welcome to the
purpose-driven life
the purpose-driven life is more than a
book it is a 40-day journey a spiritual
Pathway to help you discover develop and
fulfill God's purpose for your life
and now in grateful glory to God would
you welcome your Pastor Rick Warren
hey buddy all right
hello Saddleback
good to see ya
he is risen
[Music]
[Applause]
for tonight we're
how to play poker with Pastor Rick
Warren teaching us how to win the hand
we're dealt what's the fourth card in
our hand
the moment you change the channel
it the the Temptation loses its power on
you do not listen here's a pastor
telling this do not resist temptation
do not resist temptation let me tell you
why says the pastor yeah let me tell you
why
didn't somebody asked me but do you
believe in equality for all that's your
heart right of course this is where I
think I took issue with you before and I
will again because how can you really
as a Christian man yeah and a great man
how can you espouse genuine equality if
you don't allow gay people the same
rights to get married as straight people
that's a question that many I think
would love to hear the I'd like to
reposition it this way
at this time I call upon Dr Rick Warren
pastor of the Saddleback Church in Lake
Forest California to provide the
invocation
[Applause]
let us pray
almighty God
Our Father
everything we see and everything we
can't see
exists because of you alone
help us to share
to serve
and to seek the common good of all
may all people of Good Will today join
together
to work for a more just
a more healthy and a more prosperous
nation and a peaceful planet
first I applaud Davos for having this
session
and I applaud you for coming to it
it really says more about you than it
does about us
if you are a global business leader
you need to understand that the future
of the world is not secularism
it is religious pluralism
[Music]
we have far more in common than what
divides us when you talk about
Pentecostals charismatics
evangelicals
fundamentalist Catholics the Methodist
Baptist Presbyterian on on and on and on
well they would all say we believe in
the Trinity we believe in the Bible we
believe in the resurrection We Believe
salvation is through Jesus Christ these
are the big issues
that was a lot yeah well that's a lot
um but what I didn't hear what I didn't
hear was the
answer
to the feeling of loneliness did
you hear it did I say you need someone
right that was it and then you break
down the Walls you know it's
relationship yeah right do you know do
you know something that's interesting to
me
when we see each of these different
leaders from the emergent Church
movement
normally we think okay these are pastors
these are writers they're authors they
had got an influence in the church but
on that video we just saw each of these
men
not only is influencing the way we do
Church The Way We Believe God's word but
they're also influencing our culture
in the news what they're doing with the
U.N with the world economic Forum with
Rob Bell all of them are influencing the
way Christianity is viewed and that's
scary
because they don't stand on God's word
no the focus is justice social justice
that's the new gospel
I appreciate
these pastors for just talking because
it makes our job easy
um the Bible says in first John chapter
4 verse one it tells us exactly how to
identify Truth Versus error especially
when it comes to teachers and those who
preach beloved believe not every Spirit
but try the spirits whether they are of
God because many false prophets are gone
out into the world hereby know ye the
spirit of God every spirit that
confesseth that Jesus Christ has come in
the flesh is of God but every spirit
that confesseth not that Jesus Christ
has come in the flesh is not of God and
it goes on and on
but it's it's not just the fact that
Jesus Come In the Flesh it's the gospel
on a whole and it's Biblical teaching
and so if someone isn't teaching the
gospel do not resist temptation that's
in direct conflict in what Jesus says
resist the devil and he will free from
you then you know all right false
prophet move on and so the fact that a
lot of people are being deceived and in
Matthew 24 Jesus is instructing us to
not be deceived it's really
heartbreaking to to see because the
evidence is there if we were reading our
Bibles
the deception wouldn't be so big at
least these people wouldn't have such a
big following from Christians by
believing Christians I I think we're
that where that could um stem from
though is because in the beginning these
pastors could have been biblically sound
until you have a little bit of Pride
come out as you start getting bigger
because I've also experienced that um
like when you just are fought like
you're watching some Pastor do a sermon
and he's part of a smaller church and
just as they get bigger and bigger and
bigger they start compromising truth
just over time and so there's also that
relationship that they could have had
with the smaller church first and then
people could have been spreading that
around and then they felt like because
usually they say that
um you'll believe information when it
comes from a friend versus you know like
that's just you'll trust your friend
over anything else and so it could be
that too just like that slow build up of
okay yeah I can trust this person and so
when when they do get big and other
people start following along
at that point it's just yeah and that's
exactly what what happens you have these
church leaders who are buddy buddy with
their prisoners and I'm not prisoners
but they're they're people and it
instead of being a like a pastor they're
just like you know
Joe pastor Joe first name very very
casual they're flattening that hierarchy
everybody's on the same level and it's
just relationship it's a social club and
so they you're right they form bonds
with these people they look up to them
and that replaces the word of God
in the beginning part of the clip
when the I don't know who he is but he
was talking about the emerging church
and how it could look like replacing
pews with couches I don't see anything
quite wrong with that I mean you see the
Christian church in the beginning was
meeting in homes you know and and having
Bible study that's great it's it's the
message that is concerning I don't think
calling for change means there's a lack
of love and God has our best intentions
at heart and because of his love for us
he calls for change in different areas
of Our Lives or at least abstinence in
certain areas of Our Lives even the ones
that we hold dear and becoming
Christians is a call for sacrifice
so to remove that and say this is the
emerging Church the new church of what
can we even call a Christian at that
point if you remove Christ's principles
from it well that's one of the things
about the emerging Church it you don't
have to be Christian we'll get there but
you don't have to be Christian this is
meant to embrace everybody to bring
everybody together and you do that just
on your common your common pieces
um pizza parties you know whatever
Social Club is happening at your church
whatever social justice programs are
happening at dental clinics that sort of
thing
the goal of where this goes
once you get to the end you realize the
entire purpose and the men that are
working behind the scenes
the whole goal is to make all the
religions one and in these next slides
that we're going to go through you're
going to see why why and how they are
doing that
so they have to make everybody all
religions equal and they're having to do
that by
tearing down or deconstructing what we
classify from the Bible as Christianity
okay so you can see from Paul Smith that
what they want is a worldwide Unity a
Oneness and that's going to be a union
between eastern and western cultures
with their way of thinking and including
the spirituality so you can see wayne
Teesdale who's a monk says that um
the church would no longer see members
of other Traditions that's outside of
her life but she would promote the study
of these Traditions to see common ground
this is where we are we're trying to get
to Common Ground and not just among
Christians Christians but among other
belief systems Ray young and
summarize some of Alice Bailey's
writings
and what he said about her was this this
Unity of spiritual thought would be not
a single one world denomination but a
multicultural unity and diversity
Interfaith ecumenical agenda
so this this emerging church is the
bridge to ecumenus it's an ecumenical
path and that's where they're trying to
take us this is who Ray youngin is he
wrote These two young these two books
the time of departing and many so many
shall call in my name what can you
explain what ecumenical is ecumenical
that's a coming together when you bridge
the gap between their different
religions is it all or one
okay Eric you want to add to that yeah
there was um Pope John Paul II years ago
held a world religious leaders
conference I think it was in Assisi
Italy
and you can still find the video clips
online
they had Native American Indians shamans
they had Buddhists they had Hindus they
had taoists they had Shinto they had
every religion you can imagine they all
came to this meeting
of world religions
and every one of those other world
religious leaders bowed to the pope and
acknowledged him as the head of all
religions in the world
this this entire movement is to bring
everyone back under the umbrella of Rome
and we know from from Bible prophecy
that's going to be where Antichrist
comes from so all of these things we're
seeing that's the goal ecumenism is to
unite not only all Christians but to
unite all religions as one
so the core of the movement we may
disagree with but the coming together
the Oneness is that something that we
disagree with as Christians I assume
that the text that they would use is
John 17 verses uh 21 when Jesus is
saying be all in one just as I'm with
the father and there is a call to
Oneness when we're spreading the gospel
it's to all the world so we can all come
together and await the second coming of
Christ is there actually an issue with
that or no it's an issue when you have
to give up truth
to to come together as one that's
compromise that's no longer truth that's
compromise and we're told to worship
together in spirit and in truth so we're
throwing away truth and what kind of
spirit are we left with in in first John
chapter 2 verse three through six listen
to what God tells us
it says hereby we do know that we know
him
if we keep his Commandments he that says
I know him and keepeth not his
Commandments is a liar and the truth is
not in him
he that saith he abideth in Christ ought
himself also so to walk even as Jesus
walked so
what candy just brought out is a good
point God wants us all to be one in
Jesus who is the word of God we can't be
one if we're walking two different
directions
how can two walk together except they be
agreed we can't be one and be worshiping
the same God if one person says
homosexuality is not a sin and God's
word says it is a sin or lying is not a
sin and God's words is lying is a sin
we it can only become one as we abide in
Christ in God's word a really good
example what we're seeing today
politically as well as spiritually is we
see all the leaders going over to the
pope right to get their orders or
approval even Elon Musk who is
not a Christian but who had these
um Spirit guides when he was a little
boy these visitations and yet he's going
over
to meet with the Pope so there you have
this coming together of all different
beliefs
um
acquising to the Pope hmm who put him in
charge
all right okay Swami Vivekananda you
read this one Eric this this was
powerful
this man was a Hindu Guru or instructor
and this is what he said back in 1893 at
the uh the address at the parliament of
religions in Chicago
he said the church also has a
responsibility in our age to be a bridge
for reconciling the Human family
the spirit is inspiring her speaking of
the church through the signs of the
times
to open to Hindus Buddhist Muslims
Shakey's
John's or James taoists confusions and
Indigenous peoples
and then he says the Christian is not to
become a Hindu or a Buddhist
nor is a Hindu or a Buddhist to become a
Christian but each must assimilate the
spirit of the others that's terrifying
all right Tony Jones He says so we must
stop looking for some objective truth
that is available when we delve into the
text of the Bible they do not like truth
they look at the current culture
they say Jesus didn't live now he lived
back then we need to reinterpret the
Bible according to the current culture
and what that means for us today and
they enter into these discussions so
that's that's how they break down the
word of God
is through well what would Jesus say
today and so through these conversations
faith gets undermined and the word of
God gets undermined
I think what's scary is like in this day
and age especially with algorithms it's
very hard to know what's true and what's
not because I know like when I was
growing up and I had to do research
papers like whenever you Googled
something you would have both sides and
you'd have to sort through those
articles yourself and then they always
required us to have a counter argument
in our papers and now it's like you
research something and because the
algorithm picks up on what it is that
your point of view is it just feeds you
that over and over again and it's just
like imagine if there's something
because you know the the internet is
actually a really good resource to help
you understand the Bible as well like if
you just need more explanation on
something you can read commentaries
online and things but just imagine if
all you see are just people's blogs
showing up who you know are are
spreading misinformation about God's
word and it just becomes because that's
another thing too with social media a
lot of people are getting
God's word online through the mouths of
other people it's not even the Bible
itself and so it's just really scary
that's a good point like what you're
gonna call truth in this day and age
because it's like
it's like we're this this generation is
going farther and farther away from the
Bible they don't even know how to
interpret it they don't even know how to
cry out for the Holy Spirit and they
just they look to other people for
answers and that's actually a very scary
place to be in yeah and another thing is
that that's a good point as a human
beings we're not created as a I mean
yeah we have a brand new it's like a
computer but the thing is they to give a
lot of information like you were saying
like a you know air or truth all stuff I
mean you go cool something they give you
thousands of things too or even social
media like you're saying it's a lot of
information the thing is that the word
of God has said
you need to know God through his word
and through nature mm-hmm and if you go
in nature and go for a walk I mean it
takes time for do two miles I mean
seriously this morning it was 30 minutes
to go for a mile walking I was just
but the thing is that now is I mean you
get you go like this for 30 minutes or
10 minutes I mean you get like 500
different information
and and seriously I mean we're not I
mean I mean yeah there's no time to
meditate on his word yeah exactly it's
like go go go go you know that's
intentional time yeah
so I asked Google once not Google but
Alexa Alexa knows everything right so
I'm like Alexa
um give me a Bible verse she knows
everything because she hears everything
oh that's true
so yeah it's like that's not in my
database
and that's that's how it is today the
Bible God's word is not in everybody's
database
um Alan Jones says the church's fixation
on the death of Jesus as a universal
saving act must end and the place of the
Cross must be reimagined
in Christian faith why because of the
cult of suffering and the vindictive God
behind it they do not like the atonement
they want to undermine the atonement
um so that well number one they say it's
it's like a jihadist kind of act some of
the emergents talk about it
and how violent God is and that's not
the god they serve
so they turned Jesus's atonement his
saving
sacrifice sacrificial act for us into
something that's horrible
because we don't need Jesus to get to
heaven there's more than one way right
we don't even believe in heaven but
yes so it's an attack on the atonement
this is from a powerful book called
Ministry of healing page 4 28 and 29.
it says these theories
followed to their logical conclusion
sweep away the entire Christian economy
or the plan for man's salvation
they do away with the necessity for the
atonement and they make man his own
savior
those who accept these theories May
regard virtue as being better than Vice
but having shut out God from his
rightful position of sovereignty
they Place their dependence upon human
power which without God is worthless all
of this is a deconstruction movement
it's like it's so it's meant to
deconstruct your faith and your belief
in the and and even to the the power of
claiming these promises if we don't
believe the Bible then we we're not
going to be claiming promises over our
lives to gain victory yeah for he hath
made Jesus Christ to be sin for us who
knew no sin so that we might be made the
righteousness of God in him and that's
how God sees us and when we are under
the blood of Jesus and they overcame by
the blood of the Lamb that's how
powerful the blood is the atonement and
that's how we overcome so what the
emerging Church does as you can see it
it undermines Faith
um it breaks down the dividing lines and
tries to bring people together right
so this is all a result of Vatican II so
Vatican 2 is in 1965. and there was a
there wasn't a change in the doctrine
there was a change in the language and
the liturgy
and that was to bring people together
it's a ecumenical approach and so in the
article from Chick Publications what did
the Vatican really change
it says the second Vatican Council
brought an important change in methods
it had been decided that protestantism
could be better eliminated by ecumenical
Unity than By The Sword and the
inquisitor's torch
no longer calling Protestants Heretics
about renaming them separated brethren
that's that language softening what
happened with Martin Luther and the
Protestant Reformation
that turned the entire world upside down
I mean we had the dark ages for 1260
years under the Roman Catholic church
and when God spoke to this Roman
Catholic you know priest Martin Luther
and began to shine the light of the
Gospel then a man is justified by faith
in Christ Jesus and the blood he shed
all the sudden light pierced the
darkness
and the Roman Church said we've got to
destroy what protestantism and the
Reformation has done
I don't really see the Catholic Church
changing their stance or beliefs they
may change the words but definitely not
the core when it comes to marriage or
like human life or all these different
seemingly political things but they're
really moral issues
um so is it like a bait and switch where
all these people come together but
they like the same thing that they're
supposedly running away from is what the
church has the Catholic church has to
offer yes yes okay
yes short answer nice and sweet
all right they actually said that it
says protestantism could be better
eliminated by ecumenical Unity than by
the Inquisition and the sword so where
Satan had tried to destroy the church
from outside he realized if I joined
them
I can corrupt them gotcha change it from
the inside instead of trying to fight
them with the sword he said I'll get in
and I'll change the way they think I'll
undermine their belief in God's word as
being absolute and being sure and being
something you could stand on and he's
done more damage through that than he
ever did through the other way yeah and
then you bring in the Social Gospel
rather than the power of the Gospel so
if you're joining together on on unified
projects like bettering your community
then you're creating these relationships
as well then you're not teaching the
Bible anymore you're just teaching Jesus
love
um from the same article the change is
made by the second Vatican Council were
in liturgy administrative practices and
most important in ecumenicism while
admitting that other churches contain
elements of Truth it repeated that the
Roman Catholic Church is the only true
church
so can be your right they don't change
they change their tactics
if you would explain to our viewers what
the word liturgy actually means form of
worship they wanted to to
redo the way that we view the worship
service we'll get more into what it
looks like but that's what they wanted
to do you got to change the service
right otherwise you're still doing the
traditional way in teaching the
traditional things okay so this is Billy
Graham talking about the pope it says
Graham received the Catholic
International Franciscan Ward so that's
the other thing these pastors and
leaders and teachers they join these
Interfaith prayer breakfasts and such
and they get together and then they're
rewarded by the Pope
so they get a little pep and they get
rewarded and people respond to rewards
if Martin Luther were alive today oh
right
yeah I actually just read
um watch a documentary on that breakfast
thing you're talking about it was on
Netflix the family oh okay yeah it talks
about um all the politicians come
together for this big breakfast and it
happens on the local level service
basically yeah it's true they Pulpit
swap but Graham said in 1972 in
acknowledging the award he said while I
am not worthy to touch the shoelaces of
Saint Francis wow yet the same Christ
that called Francis in the 13th century
also called me to be one of his servants
in the 20th century whose servants are
we to be hmm he's he literally is
quoting the Bible I am not worthy to
touch the shoelaces John the Baptist
literally said this to Jesus
that is wow do you know what's scary
this is Billy Graham which I'm
and I'm gonna be careful
every person that we're that we're
sharing a name of that is involved in
this are honest or our greatest desire
is for them to see the truth for their
eyes to be open for them to really
surrender to Christ so we're not
condemning them but we're saying what
they're doing what they're involved in
is wrong
but Pastor Billy Graham it says he
received this award for quote his
contribution to True ecumenism The
ecumenical movement bringing all the
religions together he got an award from
the pope for doing what the Vatican II
Council wants done and and on a side
note I'm just going to interject this
back a couple of hundred years ago you
had Catholics and Protestants within the
Christian quote faith
you had Catholics and Protestants it's
very rare that you hear anybody use the
word Protestant anymore they say
Evangelical the word Evangelical has
nothing to do with Christianity the
Buddhists claimed to be Evangelical the
Hindus claim on their own websites that
they are Evangelical all the word
Evangelical means is you evangelize to
convert people to your religion
the reason that that word evangelicals
is being promoted now is because the
Catholic Church doesn't want people
identifying themselves as Protestants
protesters against Rome
so he also said since his election Pope
John Paul II has emerged as the greatest
religious leader of the modern world
yeah and John Paul II he was the one
probably more so
he was called The People's Pope
he was the one that everybody fell in
love with I mean President Reagan was
shaking hands with him and this was
something that was not normal
um
if you go back and you look at the the
history of America
we did not want Roman Catholicism coming
back in and infiltrating
this country because this country was
set up as a Protestant Nation
so we don't have anything against
Catholic people but we didn't want Roman
Catholicism and the Vatican exercising
her power and her teachings here
and Pope John Paul tore so many walls
down it was unbelievable
Charles Coulson says that the spread of
the charismatic through songs prayers
and worship style going well beyond
officially
charismatic circles has done a great
deal to reduce the barriers between
Catholics and evangelicals so you change
the worship Style
and this is the result it's breaking
down the Walls we're seeing a very
different worship service than we did in
the 60s even in the 70s and 80s it's
it's interesting because
um
it doesn't say Pentecostal it says
charismatic
and
what they have found and you guys with
little light Studios you guys have
revealed this
advertising
uses or exercises its greatest control
through emotion
all advertising all movies all music
exercises its greatest power on the
human race through emotion
and so what the Vatican II Council
recognized
was the easiest way for us to infiltrate
the Protestant churches
is through a charismatic form of worship
because it's emotional not based on
facts not based on intellect but on
emotional alone and even in today
and God is the one that created emotions
there's nothing wrong with emotions when
we sing We ought to be full of joy but
what has happened now is is that we are
seeing churches of every denomination
and especially a lot of
non-denominational that have begun
promoting a contemporary worship service
which is based primarily on emotion
rather than the truth of God's word you
know when you teach truth it's not fun
to hear always and it can be boring and
dry like they say that it is
if you don't love the Lord then it's dry
and boring but that's their claim
but it transforms the heart
so we do get an experience when we went
to when truth is taught truth convicts
right the Holy Spirit convicts and then
he cleanses us when we obey him when we
give up things that he wants us to give
up or do this or whatever when we follow
him that changes us
whereas this music it gives us an
emotional experience but it doesn't
transform the heart so after the worship
service oftentimes they're more
depressed and I don't want to say
depressed but their emotions drop to a
lower level than they had been before
so this this Euphoria and then there's
this
blah right but the heart was never
touched or transformed all right Phyllis
tickle was a big emergent leader she's
deceased now but she says if one we're
going to put one adjective to the great
emergence and thereby one adjective to
emergence Christianity one would say
de-institutionalized and that's what it
does it just breaks down those walls you
come together on these worship services
and we'll see in a little bit how this
came to be so would you welcome
Tony Palmer to this platform Bishop
thank you sir bless you yes sir amen
this is very important
we know that the first thousand years
there was one church it was called the
Catholic church and the word Catholic
means Universal it doesn't mean Roman
Catholic means if you're born again
raise your hand if you're born again
you're a Catholic
take back redeem what belongs to you
we are Catholics
and then there was the split at the end
of the first Millennium we had the
Orthodox east and west
two churches then 500 years later we
have Luther and his protest
three churches in 1500 years
three denominations not three churches
and then from Luther's protest onwards
33 000 new denominations
I've come to understand that diversity
is divine
it's division that's diabolic
it's true what you were saying about the
glory I agree with you of course it's
true
the glory that the father had he gave to
Jesus the glory was the presence of God
what is the charismatic renewal it's
when we experience the presence of God
and he said and I give them the glory
pragmatic reason so that they may be one
it's the glory that glues us together
not the doctrines yeah I mean now others
say I mean now it's time to go back to
Mother Mother Church they want us unify
the you know the protest is over but
they're they're saying the words while
they do the deconstruction so Tony
Padgett says that the Bible is a scary
book it's subversive and it's scary and
it needs to be deconstructed
these are your emergent leaders they're
Brian Mclaren says the Bible is not
considered an accurate absolute
authoritative or authoritarian Source
but a book to be experienced and one can
experience can be a one one experience
can be as valid as any other can
experience dialogue feelings and
conversations are equated with scripture
he's a Christian he's a Christian he's
an emerging leader emergent leader he is
an author like over 60 books so what is
his source of Truth
um probably the message the message they
a lot of the emergence use The Message
Bible it's a misnomer it's a paraphrase
right but it's still a Bible right if
that's not accurate absolute
authoritative then what is
your experience nothing yes
yeah and people follow so when you
advance through evangelizing people to
your experience you also have to
recognize their experience so when you
look at Kingdom right their definition
of kingdom is different so you and I
believe the kingdom of God right yeah
that's going to be in heaven
right now the kingdom is within us
because he resides in US but through his
holy spirit but their Kingdom theology
is different when you they believe in
universalism so everybody's saved
whether you're a Christian or
non-Christian or atheist or a witch or
whoever
you are saved
but heaven and hell are right here
there's no Heaven it's just Heaven Is
Here hell is here what I'm doing if I'm
being kind to you I'm bringing heaven to
you if I'm being mean to you I'm
bringing hell to you all right it's your
experience so but to evangelize
so to speak to expand the kingdom here
on Earth we just accept and embrace
accept and embrace
so the whole world
is saved
right but you're saved within the
context of your beliefs whether you
believe or not believe whether you're a
Wiccan whether you're an atheist whether
you're a warlock whatever
that's expanding the kingdom acceptance
we don't call people out because that's
saying I know more than you right I'm
truth you are not and so that's why we
can't give the Three Angels message we
do that is that is what we do but that's
why they don't want it given they don't
want prophecy taught they don't want you
teaching people error
because
these people it's not error for them
right so we're not calling them out of
anything
wait yes it undermines
yeah read that whole quote finish that
off because that that's powerful okay
experience dialogue feelings and
conversations are equated with scripture
while certitude Authority and Doctrine
are to be sued
in other words we we cast them aside
right it's my experience supersedes the
Bible
right but you're also calling they're
calling their experience and authority
and they're but yeah but you have your
authority too because your experience is
yours so then there is no error because
what I believe is what I believe is my
experience there's no error and there's
no sin
[Music]
right Satan wants to keep us from the
so if you're not if you're not seeking
truth if the truth is not sanctifying
you then you are not being
um recreated so to speak in the image of
God so you're not going to be ready for
when Jesus comes you're not going to be
sealed you won't be saved Satan doesn't
care how he gets you as long as he gets
you so they they cast down the word of
God and then anything goes you know
there is no writer when you take the
Bible out there is no right or wrong
so I I still don't see any hope in this
I mean it's just it's just a
deconstruction that's all I see that's
really just a break exactly that's
literally I don't see any other thing
that we have to obstruction as a step
yeah right so that's the emerging church
and then you move into
um
convergence so when you've when you've
undermined their faith when you've
created doubt in the word of God then
you bring them together
what are you going to bring them
together with well that's the worship
Styles that's um acts of service that
sort of thing just just be good just do
good one of the things that I think can
be or Brittany just asked a minute ago
about I don't see any hope
if you've got somebody that's living
under guilt because of their sins
the biblical way of dealing with that
guilt is for them to have faith in what
Christ did in taking their sins
and giving them a new life and giving
them victory over that sin but for the
emergence
instead of doing that they say the other
way to get rid of guilt is just get rid
of the law
so people say there's the hope and
that's scary the Bible says that you
know adulterers and fornicators and
homosexuals and liars and murderers are
going to have their part the Lake of
Fire but if I can tell people well
murdering's not really that big a deal
and homosexuality is not really that big
a deal you won't surely die then all of
a sudden they can be free from guilt and
continue right on living in sin and like
Stephanie brought out they won't be
ready to meet the Lord
yeah this is a powerful statement from a
book called Acts of the Apostles it says
to many the Bible has become as a lamp
without oil because they have turned
their minds into channels of speculative
belief that bring misunderstanding and
confusion
the work of higher criticism
in dissecting conjecturing
reconstructing is destroying faith in
the Bible as a divine revelation
these practices like we've just been
looking at are robbing God's word of its
power to control uplift and Inspire
human lives
by spiritualism multitudes are taught to
believe that desire or your experience
is the highest law that licenses Liberty
and that man is accountable only to
himself
from this deconstruction Movement we we
became a mega church Nation right so how
did the mega church get here so that was
by leadership network from the 80s
Bob Buford and Peter Jack are formed
leadership Network now it was a it was a
broker to the churches a resource broker
to the churches
so Peter Drucker was a businessman
and Bob Buford
um I think they were both business
actually
so what happened was the church
partnered with leadership Network and by
the way they still do these things today
conferences will bring leadership
Network programs into the churches
so that they can grow their churches
right so instead of teaching truth and
prophecy which impacted My Life as a
child and converted me they say it's too
scary we just need to bring people
together so what they do was did was
they created a research
data so what do the people want this is
the Seeker Friendly Church right what
did the Seeker want do The Seekers want
so they want coffee they want basically
a social club they just want to hang out
they want good music they want a little
short sermonette and so that's how this
came to be they did the marketing
and um and created this mega church
thing so they were looking at numbers
and it's a it's based on the
psychosocial change theory so there
again God doesn't change right but Satan
is constantly changing and so this is a
tactic that they used Bob Beaufort on
his previous website
had occultists and Mystics like Jim
Collins taking a new age spiritual
course you could contact Spirit guides
use tarot cards for spiritual guidance
and that's from a really good video
submerging Church documentary so it's so
inside the church that we're practicing
that stuff these are the people who came
together to grow
broke so they they themselves were doing
things like this and so this is the
spiritual influence
behind
this brokerage
option for
for the churches so what if I invite
these people who are doing these things
in my church what Spirit am I bringing
in right so these were influencing the
people who were bringing in the
the how to's how to build your religion
and so Peter Drucker actually was
Rick Warren's Mentor for like 20 years
so they speak the same language so these
people are mentoring our pastors and he
said Peter Drucker says that even a
stool needs three legs
religion government and businesses are
to work together does this sound
familiar to you at all and then his
understudy Rick Warren says the Third
Leg of the stool is the churches there's
a public sector rule there's a private
sector role and there's a faith sector
role so they're trying to merge
um
politics and religion and business do
you think that these people actually
know what they're doing or do you
believe that they're deceived
I you know only God knows the heart
I just have to look at what they put out
and compare it to the word of God and
say it doesn't line up you would know it
you would know them by their fruit right
that's right I mean if it's not
according to God's word I mean they're a
Liars yeah I mean look at the things
they're teaching and they don't line up
with the word of God but it sounds good
it sounds good right bring everybody
together and make them happy I mean yeah
it's fine social Gatherings are fine
it's what communal beings by our makeup
by our nature but when it comes to the
church and the responsibility of the
church the purpose of the church and
what God has called us to do it's not
just about handing out coffee so that
there's a bunch of numbers in the
building the numbers bring money though
John 12 32 if I and I is Jesus if I be
lifted up from the Earth
I will draw all men unto me so it's
Christ should be the marketing Factor
not this is not the coffee you know what
I mean they reconstruct Christ I'm
surprised we haven't even seen that I
would have thought they would have
redefined who Christ was that's what
they're doing they're good that is what
they're doing they're redefining the
church they're re-imagining Church
redefining who Christ is and you'll see
their definition of Christ is going to
be very different than who we read about
in the Bible
so basil Pennington says that we should
not hesitate to take the fruit of the
age old wisdom of the East and capture
it for Christ
indeed those of us who are in Ministry
should make the necessary effort to
acquaint ourselves with as many of these
Eastern techniques as possible
remember we we kind of began the program
with the slide talking about it was a
emerging with
Christianity with Eastern
religion and way of thinking and that's
what we're seeing there's and there's a
purpose
there's a purpose for that because the
Bible in Prophecy in the Book of Daniel
and in Revelation
it reveals at the end of the world
the power that is going to be
controlling the majority of the human
race will be the Roman Catholic Church
and you think okay so I can understand
Baptist going back to Rome I can
understand methodists going back to Rome
I can understand Seventh-Day Adventists
I can see them shaking hands with the
Roman power but how are you going to get
the Muslims the Buddhists the taoists
the Hindus the Buddhists the Taoist and
Hindus are the world's greatest
percentage population wise
how are you gonna get they could care
less about Jesus how are you going to
get them to go back to Rome well that's
why Rome
saw that they have to merge
Eastern mystical spirituality with
protestantism
because through that blending of Eastern
religion and protestantism and Roman
Catholicism you gather all in one and
that's what they're doing
this was interesting to me and and you
can still find the video clips of the
actual sermon that Rob Bell gave and
this is a quote from one of his messages
he said
now from way back when our ancestors
understood that there's something Divine
about our breath well wait a minute from
way back when what are you quoting from
you he didn't give a Bible reference
there what he's actually talking about
is the desert fathers the the Catholic
Mystics that's what he's talking about
he said from way back when our ancestors
understood there's something quote
Divine about our breath
they believe there's something sacred
and holy about the very Act of breathing
that's new age Eastern mysticism
through the roof in spiritual formation
we had something called breath prayers I
didn't do it I thought it was weird I
don't know why that and not anything
else but
um you would say a prayer like
um
Jesus Son of David have mercy on me you
would Breathe Out first part breathe in
second part so it's a cyclical breathing
repeating right and they would say that
you are actually breathing in the spirit
of God the presence of God
and it's weird because in that type of
breathing which the Buddhist and the
Hindus both do and the Taoist
they use the breath and to focus on
breath in order to achieve an altered
state of consciousness which opens the
mind for the influence of evil spirits
Rob Bell went on and he said Central to
the Christian tradition for thousands of
years have been dis disciplines of
meditation reflection silence and
breathing
and the yoga Master say this is how it
is when you follow Jesus and surrender
to God
and then he said I wonder sometimes when
we feel as though God is far God is
thinking I gave you breathing I can't
get closer
this is a pastor a well-known
hugely influential Pastor in the
emergent Church movement that is
teaching people to do yoga
and that opens the door the word yoga
literally means to be yoked or joined in
Union with the Hindu god Brahma
and he's teaching that
so it brings everybody together as one
well I don't know about this pastor or
the yoga Masters but every time Jesus
wanted God's presence he just asked for
it
right Lord please come amen we come into
His presence or before a miracle just
ask call upon me and I will be there
that's right
it's pretty much about it we don't have
to make it complicated or you know wow
that's right yeah
one of one of the things that that we
realize especially when Stephanie and I
were putting these together
if you can lead people to believe
that all paths lead to God
no matter what path that is if it's if
Native American religion if it's Aztecs
if it's Mayan if it's Buddhist Hindu
Muslim whatever if you can make people
believe that every path leads to the
same place and they call that God
then that means all religions are
equally valid
and again then you don't have to
convert anybody you don't have to call
anybody out of Babylon out of their
other religions it's also saying that
God can't make up his mind
that he can't just be direct and
straight with us he's leaving us to
figure it out and also when it comes to
someone who's just now entering into
this it's so overwhelming well which one
do I do and you know what works for me
and oh no I've made a mistake or this
feels terrible and it's just like you're
left just in the ocean drowning not
having any direction
and we have sardine again
he says I believe that the Messiah whom
we await whom we all without any we whom
we all without any doubt await is the
universal Christ that is to say the
Christ of evolution yeah when it when it
says the Christ of evolution
the new Wagers and the Hindus and the
Buddhists and many of the Catholic
hierarchy
believe that we are all evolving into
Christ Hood
they believe that this this wisdom that
you talked about earlier
that once you tap into this universal
mind or this Universal wisdom
that you become a quote Christ figure
so that's what they're looking for is
man becoming a God again
like not again like we ever were but
again as in That's what Satan told Eve
in the Garden of Eden ye shall be as
gods and Desire of Ages we're told
when Satan has undermined faith in the
Bible which we've just seen
he then directs men to other sources for
light and power and thus he insinuates
himself that's how he gets in
those who turn from the plain teaching
of the scripture and the convicting
power of God's holy spirit or inviting
the control of demons instead of
opposing Christianity the occult would
capture and blend itself with
Christianity you were wondering where
this was going this is this is where
it's taking us okay and then use it as
its primary vehicle for spreading and
instilling New Age Consciousness the
various churches would still have their
outer trappings of Christianity and
still use much of the same lingo
if asked certain questions about
traditional Christian doctrine the same
answers would be given but it would all
be on the outside on the inside a
contemplative spirituality a Christian
jacket but void of
God and then we have
um reached number nine of Alice Bailey's
10-point plan uh this 10-point plan the
U.N adopted when it formed and so number
10 is create an Interfaith movement
promote other Faith to be at par with
Christianity and break this thing about
Christianity as being the only way to
Heaven by that Christianity will be
pulled down and other faiths promoted
wow this is the goal
what's crazy is the progression because
sometimes you don't even see yourself
like when you first hear about this you
think that's crazy there's no way I'm
going to be a part of that right but
when you've been basically indoctrinated
through media and all these different
things you just end up find yourself
like finding yourself slowly believing
one thing after the next after the next
then you just end up there this is the
UN worship room so have you seen a
picture of the worship before okay very
cool
um so really when you when you think
about who God is he's reduced to a light
and this light actually represents
Lucifer
and then you have the eye of raw you
have all sorts of and that is an altar
and
not what do you sacrifice yourself
um and there's a quote that hammer scold
I don't I know I'm not pronouncing that
right but
um it was the the man who formed this
and planned every piece of it and he
says but the stone in the middle of the
room has more to tell us
we may see it as an altar empty not
because there is no God but because it
is an altar to an unknown God but
because it is dedicated to the god whom
man worships under many names and in
many forms right now churches of all
denominations
I mean like you can look it up online
Baptist Methodist Seventh-day Adventist
almost all of them are saying we're
losing church members
we're losing church members not just the
young people there's people that have
been in the churches for 30 years and
they're walking out the door and do you
know where most of them are going
to one of either new age or Eastern
mystical practices and the reason why is
because
in their churches
they have had a form of godliness but
not the power
it's been they get up in the morning
they're told you need to spend an hour
each morning with the Lord or 30 minutes
each morning so they opened their Bible
and it's just words on a printed page
it's just blah blah and they read it and
they and they go I've done this for 20
years it hasn't changed anything in my
life and they walk away because they
find or they're introduced to something
that gives them a spiritual experience
what they don't realize is that if we
will surrender to what God is telling us
in his word we will then experience
God's presence inside of us just as the
apostles and disciples did but if we if
we read but we won't do what his word
says
God can't get inside it's when we
surrender and we open the door of our
heart and allow God's word to live in us
that we have that experience of his
presence that's why many people are
turning to Eastern mysticism and those
type of spiritual experiences
and I believe that we need a Revival we
do and the Revival sometimes we're
thinking like oh yeah I mean the
church's obligation to come out with
something you know some program and
that's wonderful the churches uh to do
that Revival for the whole
congregation but I believe the Revival
we need to seek individually and start
an us first so if we don't start with
our
like you know Eric's saying like oh it
was one hour and I said well yeah that's
great but you need to have the
experience you need to say like you know
what in that moment that you go through
life
Temptation or whatever is up there and
your own personal life if you don't say
Jesus come with us come with me help me
with this problem we help me with this
thing it's going to be the same no power
there's no power and and you faith
so uh false Revival is coming right and
yeah before you just come yes so it's
gonna be crazy it's gonna be crazy out
there if you're a Christian
just wait a little bit because you gotta
be thinking like oh you know what it's
an amazing Revival over there but yeah
uh
it's gonna be mix it's gonna be very
mixed and and I think it has to be you
and God
the Revival it has to be starting in us
first and rooted in the word and not
just music
where the word is life yeah that's true
we need to be in the word none of music
yeah well I I was just going to
encourage those of our brothers and
sisters that are watching right now
please go on Little Light Studios on our
YouTube channel there
and type in coming of the cosmic Christ
because that program that we did will
really really add to what we've been
talking about here it's like yeah the
the two discussions really help each
other so that that one film will really
make a difference
uh Eric if someone would like to get in
contact with you or reach you in any way
how can they do that
um are the easiest way is through our
website it's Isaiah
Ministries
Dot online and just go to the contact
and and it'll let you send us an email
and then I'll I'll get back in touch
with you usually within a few days to a
week at the most okay and what about you
Stephanie do you have any platforms sure
um I have a website sgriffin.org
and then Facebook and
you know Instagram and YouTube Stephanie
Griffin Ministries
and email stephaniegriffin Ministries at
gmail
well thank you both so much for being on
the show here today and sharing all
these insights just another reminder of
how on guard we need to be as Christians
always be ready and willing to share our
faith but also to stand against be
strong and firm in our faith and stand
against the deceptions that we see thank
you so much for viewing the show
supporting us through not just watching
but hopefully liking and subscribing as
well if you'd like to do that
financially you can do that through
patreon patreon.com Little Light Studios
or through our website
littlelightstudios.tv and you'll have
access to exclusive content from us as
well as perks like uh private t-shirts
and things like that but we also have
T-shirts available on the broad scale
you can visit
lightwear.shop thank you so much for
watching and we will see you next week
on LED live
[Music]
thank you